про нього зняли документальний фільм
створили комікс а президент України
особисто вручив йому нагороду за
мужність хлопці нині шістнадцять це
Андрій покраса юний аеророзвідник
допоміг ЗСУ підлітковувати вирощує
колони бо ми їх знищити біля
100-150 одиниць з перших днів втор
гнення рулонщина було буквально оточене
ворожими військами на цій вулиці Андрій
Вперше у житті почув не галас однолітків
з якими грав у футбол а вибухи снарядів
Я знав що тепер уже Ну все буде
по-інакшому перші два дні ми готували
нашу хату там набирали воду поки вона
була танки були в Стороні головної
дороги по селі Ця дорога до речі зіграла
на маленьку роль взагалі в нашій
ситуації вулиця вона закрита садом
яблучним і перегороджена блоками тому не
видно домів при окупації цю вулицю
знайшли в останній чергу і встигли
погравити
дім чи два поки не прийшли ЗСУ Андрій
добре знає рідні місця не лише тому що
живе тут змалку а й через те що роками
дивився на всі ці краєвиди з висоти
пташиного польоту А точніше польоту його
квадро це вертольотик оці що дитячі але
типу якось професійніше і більш
стабільна і можна навіть чимось там ну
політати нормально і це якось так
зацікавило що потім пішов на
курс авіамоделювання у нас в Києві з 6
років відколи хлопцю батьки подарували
перший Дрон він уміє керувати такими
пташками із гори знімає відео про
природу та міста України втім до 27
лютого 2022 року яке змінило його життя
він Ніколи б не подумав що у цій
місцевості буде фільмувати російську
техніку та колони окупантів на третій
день війни тероборона почала шукати
спеціаліста з управління дронами сусіди
підказали Андрія з нами зв'язався зразу
ж місцевий активіст який запитав чи як
Пілот а вони тоді не знали що мені 15
років Вона зв'язалась з місцевим
військом він до речі от от сюди от
під'їхав коли він думав спочатку
щомітати Пілот і він сказав що типу Він
дитина і це небезпечно Але крім Андрія
Ніхто з місцевих не міг управляти
дронами тож школяр так і став місцевим
аеророзвідником для тероборони чи
запускали снарядів десь на
20% менше ніж було техніки тобто дуже от
економно було і дуже треба було точно
інформації де вони знаходяться
все це на відстані кількох кілометрів
від позиції загарбників в умовах
окупації тоді була стратегія взагалі
максимально безпечно ми і присідки
ходили я із татом був Тому що мені тато
мене координував де мені стояти де куди
іти то вони були там невелика колона
десь до 10 одиниць і там колона 70 це от
колона вона тоді їхала ще тільки до
Березівки і знайшов ще там групування
невелике надо добудованому складі
з артилерією десь на день третьої в мене
було завдання знайти
S300 пі два тижні щоденно з шостої ранку
до десятої вечора Андрій вистежував
російські колони страху в хлопця не було
батьки лише постійно пильнували аби
Андрій був на зв'язку і далеко сам не
заходив про знищену завдяки своїй
розвідці ворожу техніку Андрій говорить
із гордістю і ми вдома сидимо нас так
бах-бах Бах і мене задом сидимо наше
працювали вибухи там починали диміти
бавовна бігаються
за адреналіну така крутість розуміння що
от реально чимось міг допомогти та
солдати теж часу не гаяли 7 березня
танки-окупантів стояли за 500 метрів від
дому Андрія росіяни перевіряли особи
усіх місцевих жителів і вбивали
цивільних патріотів українські захисники
порадили батькам хлопця вивести його
адже про його співпрацю із ЗСУ могли
дізнатися до мене був Дрон я не думаю що
нас би залишили в живих Андрій з рідними
вирішили евакуюватися з села втім на
шляху з колонщини була одна зупинка штаб
ЗСУ сусідньому районі там на Андрія
чекало Ще одне відповідальне завдання
яке доручили наші військові допомогти
ліквідувати окупантів з технікою аби
відбити Один зі шляхів до Макарова те що
школяр зробив далі дозволило нашим
бійцям просунутися а цивільним вирватися
з окупації звільненої дорогою від’їхали
десь там на півтори кілометра
сфотографували буквально пройшло Хвилин
п'ять ми під'їхали назад в штаб головний
він я вам показую фото показу координати
які я зафіксував
Він знаходиться координати на карті два
рази диктує велику таку рацію інформацію
і потім там буквально за хвилину дві
прилітає
після цього родина хлопця в ту жмить
вирушила з ним на захід країни через
кілька тижнів у Польщу там юний герой
закінчив 9-й клас школи втім уже влітку
повернувся аби знову бути корисним уже
як благодійник разом із фондом Сергія
Притули Андрій запустив грошовий збір на
дрони для фронту по-перше була класна
зустрітись з людиною яка віддає в
історію України люди вдячніше допоміг на
цьому популяризація добрих справ Андрія
не припинилася про історію хлопця
створили комікс дроновод зняли
документальний фільм а влітку нагородою
за мужність відзначив президент України
втім геть непопулярності прагне нині
шістнадцятирічний Андрій каже що хоче
навчати інших керувати дронами та надалі
збирати благодійні кошти для ЗСУ крім
цього зізнається не проти знову взяти до
рук свою пташку і вистежити окупантів
для українських захисників звичайно якщо
від мене буде потрібно допомога Я завжди
допоможу можу навчити літати можу
літати рівень рівень любові до своєї
країни він настільки зашкалює я далі
продовжую жити звичайним життям тим же
самим друзями продовжую спілкуватись
жаль Звичайно що дуже багато друзів
виїхало продовжував вчитись мета Андрія
на найближче майбутнє закінчити школу і
вступити до університету в Києві а мрія
всього життя проектувати нові покоління
Дронів не лише для військових а й для
цивільних потреб у мирній Україні після
перемоги
[музика]